Hoda Kotb treats viewers with a sweet  Mother's Day surprise on Fridays Today  Show look at that hang on the river this  is our baby Oh  Hoda brought her daughter hailey joy to  work and she was totally a natural on  camera during her big TV debut  The Today Show crew showed the adorable  newborn a lot of love taking turns  greeting and holding little hailey Hoda  returned to the morning show following a  two-month long maternity leave she  couldn't help gushing over the joys of  motherhood after adopting her little  girl back in February okay can I just  say something I'm holding my baby on  Mother's Day weekend oh my god I'm so  happy  you